i have some amazing news before we start
this podcast today which i really want
to share with you and i'm so excited
about
tickets to the diary of a ceo live are
now on sale we put the tickets up last
week and the palladium sold out in nine
minutes birmingham is i think pretty
much sold out as well i think there was
10 tickets from a 1500 arena left
newcastle and glasgow
we now have tickets on sale for both of
those venues this is one of the most
artistic important powerful enjoyable
experiences that i've ever created and
if you're a fan of this podcast you're a
fan of any of the content or books or
anything we've ever produced i just beg
you give the show a chance if you can
get to newcastle if you can get to
glasgow tickets are on sale right now i
hope to meet you there i'm doing
everything in my power to make sure i
can meet everybody that comes go to the
diary of a ceo
live.com and hopefully there'll still be
some tickets by the time you hear this
thank you so much i can't wait for you
to feel this i can't wait to meet you
it was humiliating reading in the press
what had happened i got fired twice in
six months unless we could raise funding
i was never paid there weren't going to
be any jobs and after six months i just
thought i can't work with this person
you had a tough time really damaging to
me and my mental health tom didn't think
i was capable and so i resigned nothing
was going to stop stalling succeeding
people don't start banks and if they do
start a bank they
are probably a billionaire when i
started talking to people about
i'm going to start a bank you know i
could see people thinking i was totally
crazy
i hadn't raised a penny the only money
that gone into the business was my money
and he said no i'm not going to give you
three million
i'm going to give you 48.
i have the privilege of running stalling
and it is a privilege and there's lots
of things going wrong and lots of
pressures on me but it's a great
privilege to have
[Music]
if you've been listening to this podcast
for a while you would have heard the
episode i did with tom blomfield he was
the former ceo and founder of monzo bank
one of the big fintech disruptive banks
here in the uk and during that episode
he also tells us the story of his time
at stalin bank
the rival bank that he co-founded with
ann bowdan
and that episode is dramatic it should
be a movie they talk about their fallout
in the episode tom claims that anne
fired 16 members of staff in the same
day so in this episode anne wanted to
come in to tell her side of the story
but also to tell
her story and it's an incredible story
it's an inspiring story it's a story
that doesn't quite make sense in the
fact that she's achieved so much in an
industry where she was an underdog at an
age when she also admits she is an
underdog confronting stereotypes that
make her an underdog and despite the
odds being stacked against her she's
built a multi-billion
dollar bank here in the uk
it really is a crazy story one that i
believe one day will be a netflix show
think about that two people came
together to take on the banking world
they came together and founded a bank
called stalin bank they had this major
blow up
they separated
and starts again and they both build
incredibly successful multi-billion
dollar banks individually it is one hell
of a story
it twists it turns and it inspires you
so without further ado i'm stephen
butler
and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
and
humble beginnings
do you think that's a accurate phrase to
describe the start of your life
yeah it was humble um my my father
worked in the steelworks
um my father came home from work with
newspapers under his arm all greasy from
you know sort of doing hard work my mum
worked in the local department store
um and we were happy
brothers and sisters no only child
my parents married late my father came
back from the second world war um found
um
his dream wife and they had a really
really happy marriage
and school life and uh i went to the
local comprehensive school
it's a very very new school
and
i was brought up in my grandmother's
house my parents my grandmother in a
older house on the edge of a big big
council estate
and
in the middle of this huge council
estate they built this new comprehensive
school
and it was
not a very good school it was very new i
was one of the first children to go to
university
and to be honest there was a bit of a
stigma from coming from that area and
that school
and you were you were smart right
because i know you went on to do
computer science and i know people that
do computer science are smart asses so
you're definitely smart right
yeah
i think um
i did most of my studying myself the
school
um
couldn't do a lot to help to be honest
when i had my own levels i think
everybody was quite shocked by how well
i'd done
um but i did most of my studying by you
know buying my own textbooks and reading
myself
and the house wasn't a
an academic home my father left school
at 15 a 14 my mother of 15
and there were no books at home except
holiday brochures
we lived to go on holiday we were a very
very happy family we had a touring
caravan and we went all over europe um
but it was very unusual for
a daughter of that home
to be interested in studying
why
um
why i was studying or why it was unusual
why was it unusual for yeah
i think the um
my parents didn't push me
my parents believed were very liberal
you know they you know all the kids of
the neighborhood sort of hung out in our
house it was a very happy home
um we were
very very fortunate
to have just a probably a little bit
more money than everybody living around
us
um
but there was no emphasis on
on education
um
that was something i did
you know i went to the local academic
bookshop and
and i remember sort of taking a book off
the shelf you know what you do at 14 you
know what subjects do you choose
this is all much this is me
choosing these things not my parents
and you were choosing those subjects
because you
you enjoyed you intrinsically enjoyed
learning
or because you wanted to
become super wildly successful as a mega
entrepreneur i wanted a job with a
briefcase
i wanted a job in an office
i didn't actually know anybody that
worked in an office
my inspiration was from television
it was very much seeing people on
television and seeing that people had
jobs in in london in elaborate places
we're doing interesting things and i
could do that
and my parents were very supportive they
gave me as much money as i wanted to
spend in the bookshop
um yeah and they you know they went out
and bought me
it bought me a 24 volume set of
excitement britannica
the only problem was it was 1953 edition
right so all my knowledge was somewhat
sort of outdated but it was a great home
and we did interesting things
and i did well in school and i went to
university
and at that point i'm guessing you
didn't have a huge
from what you've said a desire to become
an entrepreneur
i never thought i'd ever be an
entrepreneur entrepreneurship is
something which is quite recent
you know coming out to school it was
very much
i wanted a job
that was scientific or
um
or interesting where i could
i actually wanted to be a scientist i
actually wanted to be
doing something with chemistry and
computers whatever and my mum said to me
you're gonna try for one normal job you
know um apply for a job in a bank
and i did
and the competition for the job was huge
there were thousands of people
applying for a job at lloyd's bank to be
a computer
specialist as a graduate computer
specialist
and i got the job
so when i got the job i had to take it
this is post university yeah
why did you choose computer science at
university and am i right in thinking
because it's still kind of the case now
that that was a very
male-dominated subject to choose yeah um
it was
almost all men um
my father thought i could possibly be a
metallurgist
at the steel works what's a metallic
just for some you know studies metals
metals are
made right um yeah but there was no
there was no concept of home of jobs for
women or jobs for men
um that didn't really exist i came from
a home where my mother was very
capable and my grandmother was very
capable so me becoming a computer
scientist and going to
um swansea university to study where
there were all men it wasn't something
that really fazed me
and you go off to the to university you
studied computer science you do pretty
well at university i'm guessing
yeah okay yeah you did great i'm sure uh
and then you get this job at lloyd's
bank in the graduate program and you're
there for how long
uh
four and a half years i do four and a
half years before i quit oh really is
that yeah i i had a four and a half year
thing going on right so i was four and a
half years at loinsbank
um you know great job you know so you
know did the branch thing did all the
jobs uh and then uh my first
boss told me you better tone down your
aspirations otherwise you'd get very
very frustrated
oh
and that didn't work with me i was
really really determined that i was
going to get on
so i did four and a half years at
lloyd's bank i did five years of
standard chartered bank
i did three and a half years at
pricewaterhouse
studying banks and advising banks
and uh i went to ubs
uh in uh in the city and then out to
switzerland five years out in
switzerland working for a big bank
i joined a big insurance company worked
all over the world worked in chicago a
bit
and then joined a bank in amsterdam abn
amro
worked in all sorts of places from
kazakhstan to uzbekistan to all the
places around the world i quit again
uh spent some time in fintech
before going into allied irish banks as
chief operating officer so that that
stint across all of those different
banks that you worked in across all of
these different territories how long was
that in total uh oh four weeks
so i did yeah yeah i started in 1981
and i
i
quit
to become an entrepreneur
um in 2014.
that's very atypical
oh yeah so it's very very unusual
i've also done different things in the
jobs i keep meeting people and people go
i know her ann bowdan she worked in
insurance
and i go
that's me
and they go no no no no this old there's
an amboden and she worked in in she's a
computer scientist she did computing
things uh no no that's me
um so i've had a long career
doing lots of different things in
different companies but i was a
corporate person
when i quit to become an entrepreneur
that was something i'd never done
and did you
consciously
make the decision that i don't want to
do the corporate
life stuff anymore i want to start my
own business and give it a shot
and when you did that what age were you
54. at 54 years old you decide that you
want to
go it alone
and
give up all of that corporate stuff and
all the the perks
you can say
all the perks the stability the security
of the corporate world and
yeah well i was getting up every morning
thinking somebody has to do something
about this banking industry i was sort
of ashamed to be a banker i wasn't quite
comfortable with it
and the banking industry was you know
hadn't hadn't embraced tech you know
everything was changing and the banking
industry was looking backwards rather
and forwards
and i started thinking look you know
i've got a bit of independence now i can
do whatever i want
i really like to do my own business
and perhaps i'll start a dress shop
right you know i quite like fashion you
know plus i'll do a dress shop
and
i realized
i know nothing about fashion i know a
lot about banking
and what i should do is start a bank
and but nobody ever starts banks yeah i
was going to say that's not like no one
goes from i'll do a dress shop maybe a
bank black people don't yeah
yeah i the only thing i knew about was
banks and how banks are run
and
you know people who stop banks well they
don't stop banks people don't start
banks and if they do start a bank they
are probably a billionaire
and therefore
you know i was very different
you know and
when i started talking to people about
you know
i'm going to start a bank
you know i could see people thinking i
was totally crazy of course
you know first of all people don't start
banks and a five foot tall welsh woman
definitely doesn't start a bank
yes i mean i hate to support the
stereotypes but i wouldn't start a bank
like if if i was a you know 40 year old
billionaire
white male that was six foot ten
let alone you know a slightly shorter uh
welsh woman
so you just want to because i really
this is purely for my curiosity here
because i'm trying to understand how you
like you know
because yeah i don't have the guts so um
you're 50 50 odd years old you're
currently in your corporate job yeah and
and whilst you're at the job you start
thinking about starting the bank
okay and at some point you hand in your
resignation at what point did you hand
in the resignation was it while you were
still in the job and the bank had
started moving or did you leave and then
stop start putting in the foundations no
i i decided very quickly
i
left
and within weeks
i was working on the new proposition
it's only last weekend i started
unpacking the boxes i came back from
ireland i was in ireland um
and i decided you know you know get my
notice in you know started the whole
proposition
um you know booked the removal vans to
bring me back over
and then you know put them in the house
and immediately went out knocking on
doors
um it's only now i'm finding some time
to unpack those boxes
wow how many years later
seven years
so you you leave you start knocking on
doors how did you feel emotionally when
you leave the corporate system
and you hand in your resignation and you
know you're going but you don't have
your next move like solidified you're
still building that thing you know they
describe entrepreneurship as throwing
yourself off the cliff and like building
the paraglider as you fall
how did you feel emotionally at that
phase
i think you have to cope with the fact
that you no longer have that that
business card you no longer no longer
have a title
um and
you know i thought it's gonna be
relatively easy to raise money for
stalin bank you know sort of yes and you
know sort of i've raised money in in a
job before i could knock on the photos
and they would give me the money i
needed
it was incredibly difficult
i
you know going into
lots of offices basically saying i have
this great idea okay
it's an awesome idea i'm going to build
a bank like no other bank are we going
to build the technology from scratch um
it's going to be really fair to
customers they're going to have a whole
new way of engaging
with the people that it served and i'm
going to take market share of barclays
and hsbc and lloyd's um that's all i
needed some money
people would
some people would tell me to my face
that i was never going to do it
you know the people who thought they
were being kind would say you know
you've never been an entrepreneur and
you've never run a bank as a ceo before
and
those two things are things you can't
you know raise money for
so it's tough
and
yeah there was a lot and lots of
knocking on doors
lots of people telling me
it was impossible
and
in some cases
it was really hard to carry on you know
sort of sending the emails
but i was determined
and even a glimpse of people somebody
telling me something positive was enough
to drive me on to the next meeting
and was there
a blow at that time that felt the
hardest
um an email a meeting
uh
yeah i think that there was one meeting
with with a set of investors where i
just didn't have any of the answers
you know you've been there you're an
entrepreneur
okay they ask you all these questions um
and i didn't have any of the answers you
know i hadn't got as far as you know
coming up with that part of the plan
and that felt you know that felt awful
um
but you you pick yourself up and you
figure out how you're gonna find the
answers
and you find the answers by asking
people for help you ask people for help
that have
that are in the industry you ask people
that help for help that you've worked
with in the past
there's a stereotype that people that
build technology are from silicon valley
they're like young white men
um
you know that probably went to harvard
or something like that yeah um you
booked that trend yeah when you were
walking into those rooms and having
those conversations were you aware
that there was a certain prejudice
probably acting against you oh
definitely you know um
people assume that i'm not technical
people assume that i'm not you know
capable of coding you know there's code
running in banks big banks today that i
wrote
people assume that
you have to be from silicon valley you
have to be in your 20s or your 30s
and look and sound a certain way to
build a tech company
you don't look like me or sound like me
um but i was determined to build a tech
company
and that was very very hard for people
to
to appreciate
what was what was the driving force that
spurred you on regardless of the
resistance that you clearly encountered
then what was it that made you you know
i'm gonna keep going i'm gonna carry on
knocking
i think that at that time i was talking
to venture capitalists and investors
about this concept of a new bank yeah it
is possible to build a new bank
it is possible to be a bank that
actually has a lower cost base
has a different way of relating to
customers it is possible to do this and
i kept hearing those same statements
replayed in different ways to different
routes
you know occasionally i go onto
a vc sort of website from from silicon
valley and somebody'd say roughly the
same thing
there weren't any new banks at that
stage there wasn't anybody else doing it
but i felt that there was um where there
was an echo chamber where i was tearing
my own ideas back to me or other people
are thinking the same way
i felt i was onto something
i felt that it was possible for
people to create some
organizations
that are going to change things
hmm
and you'd never done it before so would
you describe yourself as someone that
has a high level of self belief at that
point
i've managed to pull off things
throughout my career where people
thought
i couldn't go to the next stage
and throughout my career people have
looked at me and thought
okay she'll probably get one promotion
she won't get any more
and those people were normally
well working in my department a few
years later
um
so i've always managed to
go one step beyond or a couple of steps
beyond what people expected
when i started this venture i was
surrounded by people who
knew how this new world worked they knew
how venture capital worked they knew how
how you behaved how you talked how you
pitched your ideas
i had to learn that
and
i was
as a woman and as somebody who'd come
from the corporate world
i was not used to
overselling my ideas you know one of the
things about starling's whole journey is
that
we tend to over deliver
because deep down
you tend to
underplay your ideas or underplay your
success
and therefore you know stalin's
consistently over delivered and
surprised people over the years
is that a
typical stereotypical or typical
feminine quality
this idea of like because people talk a
lot about the reason why
um some of the reason why um
uh women in business um
struggle to get promotions is they're
less likely to
liquidate and oversell themselves and
demand promotions in the same way that
men do
so i'm wondering that like that
conservatism
and that
over delivering but not over promising
is something that's quite typical of
women
yeah i think it's a question of it's a
very very difficult balance
if you
if you come over as arrogant if you come
over as demanding you're not likable
if you if you're too soft and to and
underplay
what you have or what you're doing
you too soft you know sort of you can't
get it right
but
i had to learn how to sell the ideas and
it took years
since it's interesting i don't like to
dwell too much on like gender
differences but i i think i'm asking
that question as well because i remember
a vc friend of mine um and also a guy
called i think it was chamath but a guy
called chamath who's one of the big
investors and he says that the
female founded businesses in his
portfolio
always over have when kevin o'leary as
well from shark tank he said the same
thing he said his female founders um
under promise and over deliver
consistently like
and he said when i looked at all of my
portfolio companies i think he's got 40
or 50
the female-led businesses were
outperforming significantly because they
were
under under promising and over
delivering
there's a big announcement that's just
come out today in fact um if you're
listening to this would have been about
two weeks ago you'll have now released
their new flavors and thankfully i can
now talk about them
they've released a flavor which i think
might now be my best flavor everybody's
up been asking for the the sort of the
caffeine the caffeinated version of huel
they've released an iced coffee caramel
flavor which is amazing i've tried that
they've released a salted caramel flavor
if you know me you know that's my
favorite flavor in the world but
surprisingly
the flavor which i think might be my new
favorite is the cinnamon swirl i know it
sounds strange right i never would have
asked for that but the truth of life is
that sometimes the things you didn't
know you wanted are the things you
needed the most and for me
huel cinnamon swirl flavor i think is my
favorite flavor now very random but try
it delicious honestly delicious and uh
nutritionally complete win win win win
win win
so hiring those first few people
starling bank what was that process like
um and and really sort of laying the
foundations of that business
well it was all about sort of phoning up
people i knew
explaining what i was going to do
and
the idea and
really working
with every organization i knew trying to
get favors
at the the traditional
venture capital route wasn't open to me
uh actually going to um
vcs and saying can i can i can i raise
fifty thousand hundred thousand three
hundred thousand
it wasn't open to
to me
because
i i wasn't like the other people in
those schemes
i had to
really work with big consultancy firms
and tell them that i had this idea to
start a new bank
and they were going to miss out if they
didn't back me unfortunately i didn't
have any money to pay them i would pay
them once i raised the money or would
they help me
and some of those big firms decided to
back me
and lots of people in those firms took
big personal risk
because most people in those big
consulting firms thought that this was
just a totally crazy idea she wants to
take on barclays hahaha
it'll never happen no no let's try it
you know we may learn something on the
way you know sort of she got all these
crazy ideas you may be able to take them
and sell them to other customers you
know let's just just help her and i must
admit i hung out in their customer
lounges uh for years
really yeah
just chilling just yeah
okay interesting so you you you raise
money in a slightly unconventional way
considering the industry
then you start calling people that you
want to hire from the banking world that
you've met or
yeah i phoned them up
i've always been quite an unusual boss
i've always been quite um different to
the people
that i you know work with and other
organizations
people tend to be quite loyal to me
and i phoned them up and say
yeah i've got a great idea
we're gonna start this bank uh do fans
are coming to work with me
uh and we'll raise some money whatever
and that's how the team got together
so the the who was in the core team
yeah okay so there's there was a couple
of core teams okay there was the the
first core team was the bunch that
eventually went to to found monzo tom's
what you wrote about in the book and
tom's been here yeah so
that was the first cohort yeah yeah and
then tom left yeah
with the team
and i started again
i started again in exactly the same way
phoning people up and say
yep i'm still trying to start this bank
you know please please come and help me
so tom in particular tom obviously sat
here he did the podcast which i'm sure
you've heard and you've written about um
tom in the book as well how did you come
to meet tom
i met tom at a dinner right i i met tom
atte dinner in 2011
when he was working the gocardless
and i
i spotted him as being a very clever
funny
charismatic individual
that was running a business
and we kept in touch
so when you started starting you needed
was it cto he came on as a cto
so uh yeah i need a cto um i've been a
bit of a mentor to tom tom had gone to
the states to work for
grouper you know we kept in touch i'd
met him with coffee once or twice and
when he was back i mean in the uk i
phoned him up and said well he contacted
me says he's back uh and we i hired him
as cto
so he hires the cto he then builds out
the technical team i'm guessing that's
typically what he's doing yeah we
you know we started hiring developers
yeah okay and
was there because i obviously it's well
written that the there was a bit of a
fallout here yeah um
take me on that journey when did when
when did that how did the relationship
start and when was there when was there
friction
it
one day tom decides to um
to go
um unfortunately
we were about to take funding
which meant that the deal was not going
to happen and basically at that
particular point
um the funding and the team fell apart
um you know looking looking back
of what happened you know i
you know tom had a real really really
tough time at monzo
um i feel for him
um perhaps that we could have stayed
together as a team
and i could have done what i'm good at
and perhaps tom could have done what he
was good at
but you know sort of
you know that's history both monzo and
starling have done really really well
and having a bit of competition
does actually
lead to
a probably a better industry hmm the
cloners founder that came on said that
about afterpay as well
i i read that there was a funding deal
um early on but you pulled out of the
funding deal because one of the founders
was involved in a crime
yeah it was yeah
so you starling bank was going to take
funding
and you pulled out of the deal because
one of the founders of the
firm investing was involved in a serious
crime or because stalin was involved in
a serious crime i couldn't quite no no
stalling was not you know
this was this was um this was a fund
we're going to take investment about
from and one of the founders of that
firm okay didn't have the reputation
that we wanted starling is a very very
stalin believes in something we have a
mission
we believe in doing the right thing
and i think it's very very important
that we
you know especially in those early days
we maintain and are true to our vision
and
that caused a disagreement between
yourself it wasn't that it wasn't that
there was a a culture clash around
a corny video i heard that was being
produced
um
i'm trying to understand what like
because i get i get i understand a point
where founders part ways but typically
that's there's lots of small things that
happen leading up into that point little
points of friction or disagreements and
what were those um
points of disagreement
i think tom and i have much more in
common than people think
um you know sort of tom and i
often sit on panels now right so so it's
a panel of four
and you know and they go great idea
we'll have starling and monzo on the
panel and we'll have two traditional
banks in the middle you know barclays
and lloyd's whatever and um and there's
lots of questions
and somebody asked the question
and
there's going to be two answers there's
going to be one set of answers from tom
and myself who tend to have the same
view on things and then a different
answer from the from the incumbent banks
and sometimes i can see you know i look
across the panel catch sort of tom's eye
and he and you know i answer he answers
there's lots more we have in common
and it's a really it's a real pity it
you know it ended the way it did you
know you know there's lots of places in
the book when i talk about
um you know sort of
you know tom's intellect and and tom's
energy
um it's a real pity it ended the way it
did
there came a day where you you turned to
tom and you knew there was something
wrong
and you say to him you know tom is there
is there
you don't seem happy about something
here
and um
and he he responds that he's sick of
your knee-jerk behavior
hmm
how how did that feel what was
what was he referring to when he says
sick of your knee-jerk behavior
i think that
um
you know businesses are very very
stressful
i think tom
you know is
is an individual
that
sometimes has tough times
and
you know sort of
every single conversation between
founders
on the wrong day about the wrong thing
could possibly lead to that sort of
breakup
but um
wow what a story eh
how would you describe the differences
in your personalities
because it seems like that's probably at
the heart of the
clash
i don't think different personalities
lead to clashes interesting
i think that
people who have different personalities
working together can create great
businesses
i think tom
you know went on you know to
to you know sort of lead a great group
at monzo
and you know and i've listened to his
the show
um where he talked to you
and
he had a tough time
when you heard that how did you feel
about the way that the events were
recounted
be honest with me i want to know that
yeah it's a very very difficult
very difficult question to answer
and
i chose tom as a cto
um i still believe he is extremely
talented individual
and he has
you know grown a great business of
course darling is a better business
but isn't it great that
what happened
you know the story of
you know it's a
yeah
you know two individuals
come across each other
um they meet
you know sort of one decides to start a
bank hires the other person
there's a falling out
both businesses going on to really
change things
well it's it's it's the story of digital
banking in the uk
i keep wondering if you know if that
story never happened would we've all got
so much you know sort of inches in the
press to be honest it was quite a story
how did you feel when you heard the way
that he recounted the events
you're listening to it it's coming
through your ears and you're thinking
it's the first time i've heard it
but i knew that that story
was being retold
in places where i couldn't hear it
um but i'm quite philosophical about
this we all see the world
and a story in different ways
and
yeah
you know it's a
it's it's another piece in the story of
the starling monzo journey
and at this time when you and tom are
having a fallout um within stalling and
you you've realized i guess that you
know you have different ideas and
perspectives about how things should be
done and where they should be going you
hold a crisis meeting you come together
um
i guess you have those meetings i guess
because you're trying to discuss a way
a way through a way to a positive
outcome
i think at some point you realize that
there's not going to be a positive
outcome and one of you is going to have
to leave
and then you offer up your resignation
yeah so you offered to to lea to quit
styling bank
yeah i you know and that's
you've talked about you know how women
act differently to men
i was prepared to give up stalling
i was prepared to give up my part in
stalling for the good starling
and that was a very stupid thing to do
why
because it was my business it was my
idea
i got the business to where it was
but i was volunteering to give up
my role in styling
because
i wanted stalin to succeed
tom i think didn't think i was capable
somebody
that
like me
that has spent
so many years in corporate life that i
wasn't capable of delivering and
building a big tech company
and i built a big tech company
um
yeah
so he didn't have that faith in me
but i realized that i could do it and
made it happen
specifically in those days you you
decide that you're going to step away
for the greater good of the business
admirable thing to do some would say
um
it appears that
it's one of the decisions you regret in
hindsight
getting to that place or just gauging by
your reaction then it seems like it's
something where you look back and think
why did i
yeah i should never have volunteered to
resign
i should never have volunteered to go
um
that was me
saying
um that the survival of stalling was
was more important than me
and both things are important my part in
styling and the survivalist darling
and what was it that changed your mind
well i think as i write in the book
i'd sort of retreated i went to a coffee
shop went to starbucks
and
um met a guy that i'd seen in starbucks
every sunday for the you know for the
previous 10 years and you know he's a
tech entrepreneur and he came to me and
he sat opposite me and he said you know
chatted about things
and i said that i'd stepped away from
stalling because that was the only way
the business would succeed
and he said to me what you're going to
do next i said i'm probably going to
start another bank
and he said well
you don't have to start another bank you
can go back in and
and take stalin back
and
i realized that i'd made a mistake that
i needed
you know it i desperately wanted to
create starting i desperately wanted
to lead stalling
and i had to take stalin back
and i lit rich literally ran out to the
coffee shop and i can i can see i can
see i can see the street in front of me
now
and
i got into the car drove into london
um
and took stalin back
and what did that mean taking it back
it meant that
i had to be
you know totally i had to talk to people
and say
that
i had a vision of creating something
which is
an organization that does things in a
right sort of way
you know i'd been a banker for 30 odd
years and i was ashamed to be a banker
and this idea of styling was to do
things my way
and
i really wanted to
lead the organization to where it is at
the moment
so i had to make that clear
and
i took backstalling
but the consequence was that i was on my
own
i was on my own in the office
you so you walk back in the office and
say to the team i say to tom that you're
withdrawing your resignation
no um
by then they'd refuse to accept my
resignation
because um
it's a long story i don't want to go
into all the details but they refuse to
accept it because you know of certain
things um so i stepped in and took
control of stalin
and so um i heard around this time you'd
also been burgled
at home and this kind of exacerbated i
think some of the emotional components
of decision making yeah
is that accurate yeah so you know this
you know this happened around the time
of some burglaries and you know and why
you know why that's in the book is that
we you know we're ceos we're leaders of
businesses we're entrepreneurs but we're
also human
and a burglary is quite personal
and how did that impact you and your
decision making around that time
i think it was tough around that time
but
all issues and all things you do
in a business
um
are complex
and that was an added complication at
that time just adds more to the the mind
and more things to think about and
um makes you feel a little bit unstable
i guess
some bugler in your home i think has
that kind of psychological
destabilization um while you were away
what you handed in your notice at
starling and you left the office while
you're away
i guess tom's running the office
per se is that accurate and
um
you know the way that it's framed in
press is that there's some kind of like
coup that's gone on
where you know control of the company
has been seized from you in like a kind
of low-key hostile manner is that at all
accurate
i think you have to read the book yeah
you know there's a
um you know i
the book is the story of what happened
there were lots of notes and emails
taken at the time
and this was all written
from my notes
and emails written at the time
and i think it's up to the readers to
decide
you know
what really went on
and you um you go in and you say you
know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna resign
um i wanna lead this company i've got a
vision for the company in this future
and that means that you have to
fire tom
essentially that's the decision you make
you say i'm the ceo still of styling
banks so
i'm gonna i'm gonna let you go and i'm
gonna rebuild my own team and
the way that you know when tom sat here
and spoke to me he he says that you
fired the whole team
is that accurate
okay um
the story is that um we lost the funding
um you can't
if you can't pay people it's very unfair
to let them work
we were very very honest with the people
that
unless we could raise funding
there weren't going to be any jobs
and i think it's documented extremely
well in the book about all the ins and
outs and it's quite a story
and so you lose funding because tom's
quitting and obviously when people are
investing companies they're investing in
teams and peoples and cto is a critical
role the person that's building the
technology so that's why the funding
goes through and you realize at this
point i've got to basically build this
thing back from scratch
um i'm guessing you had an inclination
that there was a greater allegiance
towards tom with the with the existing
cohort of people
no not really no no okay it was more
just you you basically weren't going to
be able to
pay for them because the funding had
been pulled
um
yeah so that day so you you know
tom leaves um the the team are
are let go as well and they go with tom
and you know that starts the story of
monzo and as he's described it they
start their own bank and that's what we
now call is monzo that day after you
walk into the office
so i'm guessing i don't know whether
it's a physical office or a metaphorical
home but you walk in you're alone pretty
much is there anyone else in the room is
there anyone else in styling as an
employee at this point
it's
and how did that feel going from you
know the climb climb we're building
something here to zoo
ground zero i'm very good at picking
myself up
you know sort of at that particular
point
um i was feeling
well i haven't got the responsibility
now of of having
to raise money to pay these people
um i can take my time now to find a new
investor i can build a new team
and it didn't take long before i was
well
it's a gentleman called alan chandler
friend of yours yeah who turned up two
days later
and
stayed and stayed working for
no salary at all for nearly a year
what was um what had you built at that
point in terms of on the day when tom
and the new monzo crowd had left what
had you actually achieved as a company
what was their technology was there
nothing from the technology side had
been really done
we had a banking application so when you
when you
apply for a bank
you have to have a banking application
and it was in boxes
so you know so we had a banking
application we didn't really have much
tech okay
so your friend comes in he offers to do
the p45s for the stuff that i've just
left and just to sort of give you a hand
and then you start hiring again
a lot of people would quit at that point
and a lot of people would give up that's
a pretty significant blow as far as i'm
concerned how many people had left in
total 16. 16 people that's a pretty
significant blow to you know
might be time to go back to the
corporate world no
did that not cross your mind
not really um i
i got to a state of
having almost having a banking licence
um i had the idea i'd learnt a lot
i knew
what we needed to do
it didn't take me long
and i was starting again
you say that like it's so easy like it's
just so effortless and i know it's not
it was humiliating okay it was
humiliating reading in the press what
had happened
because the story has been told in the
press and the stories being told now
and not actually what happened um but
you know that's history you've got to
get on and you've got to sort things out
and you're going to move on
and i was
yeah i was up for it i was going to do
it again
you seem reluctant to uh
correct false stories here
that's clearly a decision you've made
yeah i think that what i don't want to
get into is he said that you know she
said this
you know i i've written a book
which is
um you know which is a very accurate
account of what happened
and my side of the story and people
allowed to have
different sides of the same story that's
okay
um but i wanted to tell my story
your friend that stopped by the office
yeah
and gave you a hand how
emotionally
important was that
and how grateful are you to them
i will be forever ever grateful to alan
uh i think that
the one person to come in
and
and be somebody who said yep this
happened but you know yeah you're going
to start again that's fine and i think
one of these symbolic things that
happened was that in the early weeks
you know when when they left you know
tom and the team had left all their
debris behind you know sort of and they
had a hell of a lot of debris um
uh
i went out one day to do some
fundraising
and
when i came back allen had collected all
the all the mugs and the odd socks and
you know the and you know all the
various medications they were all taking
and and it cleared it all up and thrown
it all away and the office was clear of
the old world and we could start again
and that was quite symbolic
and
yeah
it was
i sometimes think if alan had not come
in
you know would it have been so easy
and i'll never know but that was the
start of a new team
and you know that team you know the
the a team
and the team the left with the b team um
there she is
was you know we we attracted people that
were
i'd sought out stalling you know this
this woman is going to build a bank and
she's going to do all these things and
they turned up and
and they were awesome
okay so the team have left allen's
cleaned out the office
is there is there not a moment in you
where you you consider
packing it in is there not a moment
where you think you know what this is
april the 1st
april the 1st
that's when
you know that's when i accidentally
had an email
from the team that left
um
and
that
that was difficult
you accidentally had an email yeah you
weren't meant to be copied on it uh i
don't know i never know whether i was i
was meant to be copied on it or not um
but
they were making fun of me
and i thought well
is that the day i'm going to give up
but i said nope you know and i went back
in the office the following day and
carried on
making fun of you in terms of
your management skills your something
you've done or said or very personal
things
no it's a question of you know you have
to read the book about it but there was
a prank about them being arrested
um
but you have to read the story to
understand the
the nuance but that was the only day
that i thought
you know can i carry on
and that lasted an hour
but i was absolutely determined were you
upset reading that email
i was panicking about them i was worried
about them why
um i was worried about
the fact that they could be in real
trouble
and
yeah i hired these people they were
friends for years
uh the
and i like them
you can't suddenly
um
you can't suddenly cut off all
connection with people that you worked
with even though this thing had happened
to me
did it put a fire in your belly that
wasn't there before because you know
events like that can they can kind of
send you one or two ways oh and they can
kind of send you i guess they can also
send you both ways at the same time but
they
typically if we're just kind of broad
strokes they can they can devastate you
to the point where you you know don't
get out of bed or they can motivate you
to the point that you work two times as
hard
nothing was going to stop stalling
succeeding
after that happened
so it's
it's the work twice as hard
yeah and did you did you really did you
were there moments like where you
you
know you what you just put that extra
effort in and you you know you become a
little bit more determined because of
that like moments you can think of
because i know that i'm a human being
and i don't care if i was in that
situation i swear to god i'd have a
picture of their face on the wall my
team would be hearing about it every
five seconds that's the guy i am like it
or not don't care i do that about all
the competition we have i it motivates
me and it is what it is you don't have
to like me
so i'm asking the question like did it
did they become a
a real significant competitive driving
force in your life okay as a woman it
can't be bitter okay you can't show that
bitterness
um why you can't you you have to be you
know you you have to internally put your
energies into
um into stalling
um you know starting
starting succeeded styling is
a successful business
that i'm terribly proud of
and
yes
when i take a lot of inspiration from
other people's books and whatever
most
most businesses have had a
near-death moment
it it it happens so often
that the best businesses the best
entrepreneurs have had times when they
lost it they almost lost it but they
recovered
this was mine
and
it played out very publicly
and
i learnt a lot from it
and i decided to continue
and i think stalin and me are better for
it
when you started to rehire the new team
yeah i'm guessing you made different
hiring decisions in terms of because of
what happened
did it influence the type of people that
you brought into the business
for the
chapter two
not necessarily
i think that
yeah i i didn't set out to get um
a different set of personalities
i could focus on getting more qualified
people and
higher caliber people because
i had a better business proposition
it was a year in 18 months in you know
it wasn't a blank sheet of paper
it was
a fully formed proposition
that it almost raised money
where we had an application for the
banking license that was almost fully
formed
so it was less risk for those people
coming in
and i also had spent 18 months figuring
this thing out
i was better at selling the idea
so the second time around i could bring
in a you know i don't want this to be
derogatory on you know tom or whatever
i hired a
higher caliber
more appropriate set of people for the
problem we had to solve
okay yeah i think that's i think that's
a natural thing i think
i think even in you know
monzo's business i'm pretty sure when i
had the conversation with tom he he
speaks about
hiring and you know hiring a different
caliber of person to meet
an evolving business challenge
especially i know i know particularly
monzo's case they did start bringing in
people from like the banking world and
stuff like that and even in my business
i talk a lot about how we did the exact
same thing i at the very start
didn't quite know the caliber of talent
that i needed or the you know their
experience and in year three of my
business i realized that the first two
one or two years of hires that i'd made
weren't adequately uh experienced in
solving the problem i had to solve and
also the type and scale of problem you
have to solve evolves right when you're
one two years old it's a different set
of problems to when you're like a
thousand employees right so
that makes perfect sense pivotal moments
then so chapter two of starling um
funding
yep
what was the pivotal moment with getting
getting the money in the door it was
very very difficult again uh yeah it was
um but two years in
i was approached by
um a family office
and i wouldn't return their calls okay
you know i was absolutely determined
that i was going to have a vc these
people i knew it's going to be
these well-known firms um or you know my
investment bankers are going to find me
this sort of investor
but i was approached by
a
family office
that had seen
an article about tom in bloomberg
and had investigated what's going on in
the new bank scene in the uk
and wanted to talk to me
and i started conversations with them
and
it took a while for me to actually
engage with them i'd never heard of them
and i wasn't going to talk to people i
didn't know
anyway i ended up going on a getting on
a plane to the bahamas
oh that's when you know they're rich
it was a yacht wasn't it it was a yacht
and spent three days being interrogated
by a gentleman called harold mcpike
i was an argument algorithmic trader
um and
uh he
he asked me the most complex questions
that anybody ever asked he was really
into the detail
and yes
at harper's four um
i joined him on his
yacht
and
how big was this young it's a big yacht
more of a ship
it was a big yacht okay uh and uh yeah
he asked me lots and lots of questions
about
me
about the business
and he was very very detailed
and at 11 15
in the evening
he offered me 48 million pounds for 66
percent of the company 66 percent
i read that he said he he said something
to you like uh i'm not going to give you
the three million
yeah
i was trying to raise three million okay
i was trying to raise three million
that's all i needed was three million to
get to getting the the banking license
so the idea was to raise three million
and then 15 million and 30 million i
only wanted the three million i hadn't
raised a penny the only money that gone
into the business was my money
so it was impossible to raise money
uh and he said yeah so you said no i'm
not going to give you 3 million
i'm going to give you 48.
christ sounds like chris tarrant for me
wants to be millionaire that's mad
40 and how did you feel so there's two
real things here that's a huge amount of
money but that's also 66 of your
business
[Music]
tough
and at that particular point you know
that all the other things that you're
working on all the other leads are going
to
going to go yeah you may have 40 50
different leads you're working on
you're going to accept this offer and
sort of somebody else now controls the
company
but with 48 million you have a situation
where you can build the test best tech
in the world
so
now i've been doing this for two years
and
it was really difficult
and i had somebody who really understood
what i was going to do
was super intelligent
that actually
believed in my conviction i could do
this
but i was have to give up 66
but it would mean
that i could build something that nobody
else had ever built
i mean
in that moment he's valuing what is and
correct me if i'm wrong here essentially
an idea
yeah
it was a 16-page deck
he's valuing a 16-page deck at
72 million
how long did you have to think about
that decision
probably about 30 seconds really
and how do you feel about it because a
lot of people that look back on those
fundraising decisions it seems that
every startup entrepreneur regrets how
they value their bit business at the
start because they always especially
when it becomes a multi-billion dollar
company they feel like they sold
themselves short how do you feel about
it
he's not listening
he's too busy in the bahamas
i think that
it is more and more important to
actually create this vision
i was so excited that
i could now start
and we eventually signed the deal
on the 23rd of december and submitted
the banking license on the 22nd
of december
it was
finally you know we could we could start
it was hugely exciting
did you celebrate
well i couldn't actually celebrate that
we didn't actually have a term sheet for
another three days
so you know it was on the saturday night
i was flying back
and i had the term sheet an hour before
picking up the flight
but once you'd signed the time sheet it
was all signed after you so you never
you never celebrate term sheets
uh you celebrate getting the money in
the bank when the money came in the bank
did you celebrate
how yeah that look
uh how did it look you open up your app
where barclays whatever oh 48 million
yeah
it's it was back to the bahamas it was
very exciting it's very exciting and
it allows you to do so much
was it terrifying as well
was it scary it's a lot of
responsibilities 48 million pounds of
someone else's money
yeah
and that's why entrepreneurs that take
external funding
are so committed to do a good job
there's a huge amount of responsibility
to deliver
you can't just um
you can't walk away from it
once you got that investment you have to
deliver it's so important and how much
money have you raised in total now
for starting 600 700 600 700 million
pounds wow
i could have done so much for that so
what have you learned about raising
investment
well that if you were you know there'll
be a lot of entrepreneurs listening to
this
um
who have a lot of like unhelpful
stereotypes or thoughts about raising
investment god some of them will think
the only way to do it's like dragon's
den
right um what would what would you tell
them now having gone through this
process so many times
take the money
okay so there's a huge amount of
huge mud written about you know you need
to go for these sort of investors of
those sort of investors and you need to
pick your investor or whatever the vast
majority of people
can't pick where the investment's coming
from
you know only one percent of vet venture
capital funding goes to women founders
right so you know if somebody offers use
the money
you got to take it
because it comes around so so rarely
and a lot of people worry about
valuation
not relevant
you know most businesses fail most
entrepreneurs don't get their businesses
off the ground
not because they don't have good ideas
not because they not good people but
they couldn't get the funding
and do you think it's hard to raise
money yeah very hard
venture capitalists tend to invest in
businesses that look very very similar
you know if you look at if you if you
read paul graham's works oh yeah yeah
you know he talks about really
that
teams need to look like this and and
things are done in this sort of way you
know i would have never got any y
combinator
vc program funding because i'm not that
sort of entrepreneur
and a lot of investing by
vcs
they're looking for
carbon copies of businesses they've
invested in in the past
and the really great ideas don't get
that investment
and real great ideas from women founders
don't get great in don't get significant
investment
interesting but there's a lot of money
out there isn't there
yeah that's what i've come to learn is
there is a lot of money out there
there's a lot of money out there when
you're successful right starting now is
it's a big business
1600 people two and a half million
accounts
doing interesting things
we have a reputation
but the fact that you know and
occasionally
you know they publish how much
money in the uk has gone to
women
founders
and
it's a lot of it's gone to me
[Music]
so so
i think we have to be very realistic
that
you get to a point where
you're a success and people then want to
invest
but the majority of the time at starling
it's been really tough
it's been really tough so what it when
you reflect on your corporate career and
you can trust it and compare it to your
entrepreneurial career
what was the really surprising tough
part on a personal level
and this is really why i started this
podcast
they
all jobs are tough a corporate job is
very tough
i think that
being an entrepreneur it's far more
personal responsibility
as an entrepreneur there's nobody that
in all hiring decisions
um somehow ended up with you making that
first hiring decision you know we have
1600 people but those you know some were
up in the chain i hired one of those
people right that made that hiring
choice
um anything that goes wrong is is my
responsibility um and all mistakes are
probably down to me okay so there's a
lot of personal responsibility
and that responsibility
gets more and more as more and more
people depend on it
but isn't it fantastic
isn't it a wonderful buzz isn't it
isn't it wonderful to
to have a platform really
i
i fundamentally believe that
financial institutions lost their way
and stalling is doing the right thing
and somehow people
have said to me that i've created the
organization that i wanted to run
because i quite like running
organizations
and i wanted to do things in a different
sort of way
so finally i'm running the organization
that i've been wanting to run for the
last 35 years and that you wish to exist
as existed as a customer yeah i think
that you know i've been very lucky i
i've always had a great relationship
with money
i but the vast majority of people in
this world
have a bad relationship with money
it doesn't go well for them
and you know they deserve a better bank
i went into banking you know because i
wanted to do interesting things i wanted
to come to london and i wanted to be in
tech
but i also wanted to do something that
was
respectable worthwhile doing the right
thing by people
and
banks stopped doing that
and i'm much more comfortable
being accountable for the organization
that is stalling
and it helped you to i guess alleviate
that taxi cab shame you
reference where a taxi driver asks you
what you do and you don't want to say
banker because there's so much stigma
and shame around
the sector
are you proud to talk about
yeah i'm proud of talk what i do i'm
proud to talk about
yeah i'm proud to talk about what i do
and what i stand for
and having a bit of a platform
to nudge things in the right way
you know i
i'm only a small cog in this whole world
but if i can do my bit
to make things fairer
in a couple of
segments
you know i should do that and i'm
enjoying doing it
you talked about the buck stopping with
you
all problems are your problems or hiring
decisions are ultimately lead back to
you by x degrees of separation
when you're and especially you know the
other part is the industry you're in
it's not an easy and easy industry
customers you have millions of like
customers that are you're dealing with
their money
which is the one of the most emotional
sensitive things you can deal with with
any customer
um
the the emotional toll
must be extreme i mean tom sat here and
it was the first window i'd had into how
brutal
uh emotionally brutal fintech and
managing a bank
can be yeah
managing a bank you know so yeah i
listened to what tom said
and all the things that tom said happen
in all banks
right that is what happens
but it's my job
it's what i do
um
[Music]
it's what the people i work with do
and sometimes it's
sometimes you read emails and people
that have been scammed out of their life
savings
you have emails and you have cases where
you know gamblers have lost all their
money
you have to deal with people who
have lost their son in some tragic
circumstances
we have a window on people's lives in
all sorts of circumstances
we have to be responsible we have to be
empathetic
and we have to guard ourselves from the
bad guys out there
what we do means that we touch people in
all sorts of ways when the most
vulnerable
whether they've lost somebody whether
they have
you know they gambled all their money
away or whether they've been scammed
that's a responsibility
but it's not just me that has to take
that responsibility we have
we have hundreds of people that talk to
customers every day
that see customers when things are going
well and things are going badly
it takes huge amount of energy and
sometimes they're listening to calls and
it really impresses me how
young people you know who are new to
their careers who
are so
empathetic so in touch with real people
and really helping them you know i take
my hat off to them
what do you do to protect yourself
mentally from
the
chaos of running such a big business
that has such a
you know is dealing with such a
sensitive topic for people what do you
how do you protect yourself from
not losing your sanity
yeah
i had a great mentor in this
my father
my father um was brought up in a home
where um his father was in the first
world war
and he came back from the first world
war with what you now call
post-traumatic stress syndrome
and they didn't call it that then they
called it you know shell shock
and he
he was brought up in that home where his
father was had good days and bad days
and things were quite fragile
but he had my father had a great way of
talking about her feelings and emotions
and
what you do
to talk yourself up
and
and how you make yourself happy
and we had a home where we talked about
this and how you counted your blessings
we weren't religious at all but how are
you how you
have you took energy from what's going
right rather than what's going wrong
and
he was a great mentor he taught me this
and i think the dedication in my book is
all about
you know thanking my parents for
teaching me that happiness is something
that you can cultivate
and treasure
because not everybody has it
and
i think when i
i'm in a sort of situation where things
are tough
you can do things to change the chatter
in your head
to realize that you're not the center of
attention you know sometimes you know
it's not about me
you know not not everybody's looking at
me
everybody's looking at their own life
and thinking about their own problems
and
i am very very fortunate
i have a huge number of things that are
going right for me
and i have the privilege of running
stalling
and it is a privilege and there's lots
of things going wrong and lots of
pressures on me
but it's a great privilege to have
so do you see that as a your sort of
coping mechanism there is a almost like
a
almost like a childhood disposition that
was
taught to you like it's a perspective
that kind of defaults to optimism seeing
the glasses are full defaulting to
gratitude that's kind of acted as a
protective yeah i think it is i'm still
quite excited by it all right so coming
here today i was excited right this is
this is something which is look i am
ever so fortunate
to be a person who's doing what i'm
doing to talking to you that's going to
be broadcast this is exciting
when i come back into london you know
i'm driving back into london late at
night and you know and i'm going through
the city
i'm
i'm still excited
i'm like a kid that's coming to london
for the first time this is an exciting
thing to do
i'm
[Music]
yeah i'm loving it all
right
such a strange question to ask but um
that is somewhat unusual it feels it
feels like well is it maybe it's just
because
the conversation i had previously was so
you know like the red phone by the bed
tom described you know yeah i have a
phone by the bed and it never leaves the
the yeah the phone is by the bed all the
time and that's the like the emergency
call me if there's a crisis phone yeah
but that's the job i get paid for
but there's a huge thing
there's a huge amount of things that
come with this job
you know i you know i appear
in front of the treasury select
committee and get grilled i you know i
have this sort of grilling from you i i
i
i can talk to interesting people
i have the opportunity of building
something i've always wanted
that's a huge huge privilege
i really think that's a really
underestimated defense mechanism against
life is if your default position is to
view the
you know to count your blessings as you
say and view the half as glass full then
it's it's harder to slip into
the trap of um
my expectations are being unmet because
of the difficulties of my life and a lot
of what we've discovered from this
talking to guests on this podcast are
when your expectations of how the world
is meant to be going go unmet then you
slip away into unhappiness and misery
and
yeah you seem to have a default to
gratitude essentially which is
causing a very mentally sort of
protective have you ever been to therapy
have you ever had like any professional
support in that regard no no
i read a lot
i read um i read
i read hundreds of books
i
read you know i read every self-help
book i get my hands on i read every
single banking strategy book
i've always done it i
i love understanding things
the the personal
so this is interesting one of the things
that
um
you said well kind of two points is that
you don't have work-life balance
it's all it's just all work yeah when
people hear that they go they sympathy
like you know they think
they think you're like like i feel a
similar way to some degree maybe it's
changed recently but
i that was my life and
i don't want sympathy for it because i
actually love what i'm doing every day
but then you know i read into your story
and there's sort of connected points
there where you say
um
about how women are sort of conditioned
in our society to think happiness equals
having 17 kids and her husband and how
you would like to do you know buck fat
narrative yeah can you talk to me about
that so like the personal
i don't want to call it sacrifice
because that's the loss of something but
the personal
balance you have in your life and also
you know you talk openly about not
having kids yeah um
look you know sort of um
you know the right man never came along
uh it wasn't something that i decided
against
but there was never any assumption in
the family home that i would get married
or whatever but the right mind never
came along
and as far as children i never made the
decision not to have children
just that
sort of i was busy and then it was too
late
but i think that people compare
um
to
quite an idyllic state of you know
marriage and two children and
them all living in a wonderful home and
you know sort of everything being
um fantasized life of a family
and
the majority of families are not like
that
i have
i am really really happy
that i've made the right decisions
and
yes
i'd say
i get asked about it occasionally and
brave people ask me about it you know
people who are not brave trying to go
around it
um
yeah
you know but one day i say we'll marry
you never know you know the right man
may come along um it's unlikely to
happen with children
i always struggled in when i was running
my business to have any kind of
relationship with anybody i was a total
failure because i was obsessed as you
say like work-life balance it was just
all work i was in the office saturn
sunday and i found it incredibly hard to
find someone that understood
the peculiarity of my
life dynamic it was only upon leaving
that business that i actually managed to
like you know
like piggle something together like
higgledy you know like put some pieces
together
which is probably resembles a
relationship now but um
it's very difficult finding a man who's
prepared to listen to me going on about
my career for three hours
um
we've had it's not no we've had a lot of
guests come here that are you know
female founders that have said a very
similar thing yeah and also an
interesting narrative which i i want to
talk about which is like men can be
emasculated
is this true
chrissy came here and she's she's a
successful fan and she said that yeah
like
men can be emasculated by the success of
a
a woman if she's like bringing home the
bacon or if she's you know the
career-driven one
do you find this to be true well you
know i had a lot of coaching from
friends before going out on a date and
going for goodness again don't ask for
the bill okay for goodness sake and
don't you know don't leave the table to
answer a call
right so
good to see you like a really really
good deal coming up no no no no this is
how it works and okay you go on a date
and you pretend he's he's awesome
and you don't go off and answer your
phone
and you don't try and pay the bill okay
that's how it works that's how it works
for most people
but you know
sometimes work is more important
wow
oh god and you i i read some as well
that you said that you could write a
separate book about your dating
yeah yeah dating experiences
yeah i've done a lot of that yeah a lot
of dating
um it doesn't work it doesn't work it
doesn't work
and you you pinpoint the way that you
are in terms of your like your focuses
your ambitions your
just you know all of that stuff as
making it difficult
that's the thing that makes it difficult
look if i put a lot of effort into it i
would have probably made something work
um the trouble is i put a lot of effort
into
my job and my career
and i probably get a huge amount of
satisfaction about with that
and it's sort of taken priority
but that's great
you know you know i've
i've got a great job
um you know i'm doing this sort of stuff
you know you know what could be better
you know sort of being in the situation
where
you can talk about things and you
and you have success
yeah it's good as you reflect back on
you know the the and that started her
career as an entrepreneur
and
the naivety that she must have
undoubtedly had going you know
what would you what was
some of the key sort of pieces of advice
you would impart on her and say
i just wish you knew this and be careful
of this and
i i think it's the
the question that people
always give you the wrong sort of advice
what i what i caution about is that
there's a lot of people out there giving
bad advice
because when you ask somebody about what
you should do or how you raise
fundraising or you know whatever you do
about your business they haven't got a
good idea so they give you something
because they feel as they can't say i
don't know
so be cautious of those mentors that
actually don't know anything
and there's so many people who have you
know the the
the vc world is full of people who are
you know
you know finish their careers
that are wandering around vc land
trying to tell you what things work and
how things work i've never run a
business a lot of that is absolute
rubbish and you have to just stop it
um one of the biggest lessons i learned
is a lot of the things that i knew was
absolutely 100 certain of was actually
wrong
right so forget about it the world's
move on be relevant
and do you want to sell starling bank
what's the plan do you want to you know
you want to list it on the stock
exchange do you want a big
incumbent bank to come along and buy the
company so you can sail off to the
bahamas with that guy on the boat or
no i think that would probably list in a
couple of years time
you know i wanted to be
i want to be important i want styling to
be something that changes financial
services forever
i'm enjoying myself you know i'm
i'm now ready to quit
this is
i'm on a roll
and you must have had some offers right
because you know a couple of people
coming along saying yeah yeah brown
envelope 100ml
see you later no
it's
like a it's a unique opportunity you
know imagine put yourself in my shoes
1981 i came to london
to start my career in banking
and
rocked up at lloyd's bank as a graduate
trainee
nowadays
you know i'm i'm running an important
bank in the uk
and i founded this bank
and it's much better than the incumbent
banks and it's at the start of its sort
of
300 years rather than the end of it
yeah it's incredibly exciting
um yeah i have to pinch myself
it's really happening
yeah you know it's it's it's truly
remarkable and you're right i did give
you a grilling there a bit on a lot of
the key points because there is you know
there is such a
interesting banking narrative banking
war narrative going on in the fintech
space at the moment and but you know the
overarching thing is just you know i
find your story to be just so incredible
and i find it to be like genuinely
unbelievable because
you say it in such an effortless way you
say you talk about these events and even
the fundraising stuff and you know the
stereotypes of being a female founder um
that doesn't fit the existing
stereotypes of tech bros out in silicon
valley that are all like 21 from harvard
and they're all dropouts and to
persevere against it all i suspect
is significantly maybe 10x harder than
you actually make out
because like i know how hard it is
anyway but then when
the deck is stacked against you and the
ways that i i know it it is because i
understand stereotypes and the climate
and especially in the banking world like
what kind of lunatic starts a bank right
and i i was i was fortunate enough to be
slightly privy to some of the early
processes of like getting a banking
application because we had a lot of
fintech startups including banks like
monza approached us very early and asked
us to help with the marketing
so
and then and when i was sitting in the
rooms maybe five six years ago they're
all talking about eventually getting
their banking licenses or something
and uh that corner was turned eventually
but it's just remarkable and it's
unbelievable and there's very few
entrepreneurs
in the uk or really anywhere in the
world that i've encountered that really
managed to
take on a really stubborn incumbent and
as it relates to the banking industry
here spotify is one of the examples i
sometimes think of
because there was no way you could make
you know move move away the rights and
the music rights and move it to digital
and then charge people like so it's that
again i consider danny like to be a
lunatic but yeah incredible yeah it's i
consider this to be the same so yeah
thank you for the inspiration thank you
for the courage and i think your story
is one of you know
it's one in
you know 100 million i do have one
request though and this is where the
diary comes in okay
okay so
um so what we do with all of our guests
when they come on the show is they all
write a question in the diary for the
next guest right
so our last guest wrote a question for
you
do you really understand the purpose of
your life here on earth
no i don't i think that i've
nobody ever
sort of
discovers their purpose until probably
too late
um and i think
thinking about that question too hard
is probably
too difficult
i think the purpose your life
will only be discovered
once it's too late
you don't think it's
what you're doing now
would you suspect i think i'm on the
start of a journey rather than the end
i think
i want to do more than just
make stalin the
best bank in the world
i think starling will do its bit
to help people with a financial
health
but i think it's also important to
nudge society in the right direction
and i can do that with a platform of
stalling
nudging society in the right direction
in terms of
yeah fairness fairness equality yes
i think the world is very unfair in lots
of different ways
and it's not just fair between countries
there's very very you know different
people have different experiences this
life
you know i have been extremely fortunate
but the girl growing up next door
had probably had a very very different
life to me
and
by an accident of birth
we experience a very very different
life
i'm getting prime minister vibes
i have no no intention of becoming a
politician it's far too hard
okay but you can as you say you refer to
starting as a platform and that's you
know being able to influence the
electorate
is equally important um as as being the
puppet in charge so
i'm gonna ask you to write a question in
the book thank you so much for coming
today it's been awesome thank you very
much for inviting me i've really enjoyed
it thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
you